morning millennial who are my favorites
millennium there's good these
Millennials because they had a holiday
weekend but they had a workday yesterday
without the toes so they're suffering we
memorialized Memorial Day for two days
it was wonderful
I'm not I'm I'm not sorry but like I
know the struggle I guess because like
you've never had to like go back to like
a desk job after a holiday weekend and
not have your paper podcast that's true
but I don't really listen to podcast
except my own
because there's nothing worthy yeah
podcasts they don't really do it for me
but now that we have our podcasts like I
listened to some of our episodes
sometimes when I just like want random
noise in the back and I listen to old
ones and it's so funny I would actually
rather die than listen to the sound of
my own voice I listen to like Caitlyn's
podcast I listen to some of stassi's
like a there's a yes that I like I used
to listen to stassi's when I like worked
yeah at a job I just was really really
what my name was mentioned once oh yeah
we listen to it on the plane that was no
I usually listen like wait for it every
episode to come out and then I just I
don't know what happened it might make a
little louder but we are back and we are
so excited to share with you the news of
the day and we have a special guest
today well you were just so weird to
share with just like China I think
Kansas should I special guest today who
is Ryan Serhant oh yes if you want to
learn how to sell it like Serhant then
stay tuned to the end of the show cuz
they'll be joining us a little bit later
so if you have comments for him
feel free to go comment on our Instagram
I posted in cute little Jeff gift
whatever you want to call it or just
comment on the Facebook or YouTube
streams we will be tuning in yeah give
us your comments and we will ask me your
questions oh that is just so funny I
just I glanced over at the comments and
someone said Claudia looks super thin
and do you know what I did last night
but I like bread every mean thing ever
written about me really yeah how do you
how did you go about that energy like a
dark dark hole like I've read it vibe
you know he went on reddit I went on a
couple places I just looked wanted to
see the feedback of the show and like I
think it's actually really helpful to
read things where you angry but not when
it's just like superficial [ __ ] ass
things like I can't believe you
you know like literally didn't mean a
thing do you ever hear it sure so what
was I'm scared do you think like Claudia
like feels bad about like having such a
big extravagant wedding and the fact
that she looked so ugly like that so me
but I guess we said the same thing about
Meagan Marcos like what goes around
comes around
totally but it came around first night
she said it first
all right really bad wow that's really
crazy yes the general yuwen here the
general consensus about both of us sure
okay well people think that I really let
myself go in terms of my way and you
know what I don't disagree it just like
mean when you say it do you know what I
mean right because they're not saying it
in a nice way
no and then people are also like saying
like we just looked so Haggard on the
show cuz I guess we had hair and makeup
at oath but like we didn't even we
didn't hear less hear no I mean I feel
like I do the same analogy
I'm just getting better at my makeup
actually you know what recently I have
stopped doing my hair first like this is
my natural hair I have worn my hair
natural probably since middle school
yeah just because when I've been
straightening it it just looks a little
too flat and I've been sleeping on it
wet and it's like this doesn't really
bother me no it looks like I'm sure he's
like really bother me always had to do
something about it
but just with this length it kind of
works the demons are growing up so maybe
that's what they're talking about they
notice that I've that I've let my
natural hair I guess like the only thing
people I think I took it as a compliment
that like the only thing people were
saying was like about my physical
appearance and like even if I looked the
way people wanted me to look they would
still have things to say about my
physical appearance right so at least
you know up saying things about like me
personally like you can say anything the
show is hilarious like everything about
the show is great you want to call me
fat like well fine it's like the obvious
choice you know um I can't believe you
did that you are a brave right so I feel
like a really bad mood afterwards and
then I really wish I didn't do it but
you know it so it's good it's nice to
hear like the worst possible things that
people are saying about you and it's
like you know that's not so bad
no totally like that's exactly it like
if the worst thing someone says about me
is like if something superficial like
about like okay obviously like I'm a
little chubby like okay I'll live you
know 100% whatever
speaking of talking [ __ ] about people uh
here the past five stories thank you
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast I really could use
some toast I'm so hungry but ever since
I read those things about me like I'm
not
anything really no have you eaten since
no I did what you have grilled chicken
from someplace huh I'm really hungry now
that I think about it anyways now that
much happened this weekend which was
great for us because like we didn't have
to like jump on the horn and record a
podcast with our dead podcast aquit was
so dramatic you guys it was so dramatic
but speaking of our dead podcast
equipment it is now brought back to life
and our fourth patreon episode is up on
our patreon account it's a conversation
one-on-one between me and maims
talking about our engagement day I
finally got like to know some of the
behind the scenes that went down some of
these things that were stressing him out
talked about moving in together and we
answered all of the toasters questions
which as usual were premium and
hilarious ya know it's honestly really
easy to do the patreon episodes because
the patreon users come up with like
really interesting dynamic questions not
just like so like how to do is mean you
know like I can't even answer that
question like they were asking means
like how does me wearing lipstick all
the time like a Spectre that's a great
question and you know what we didn't
even realize how much it affects us
because you whenever I see him when we
go like go out to dinner or something
and we just have to pack like we're like
six-year-olds you aren't into each other
anymore and it's really annoying but
we've never verbalized it so now I think
I'm gonna make it to like start wearing
more mad without glasses yeah so thank
you toasters so the fifth patron will be
up today
similarly probably like more exciting
for you that no kidding it's me and Ben
we're gonna do a one-on-one convoy it'll
probably get like really disgusting like
we'll probably just end up talking about
like duties and stuff because like
that's where it goes and then I know
what duties our duties are people do for
sure feelings also one where
housekeeping announcement before we
officially jump in because like I
literally I'm having an angina this
morning with how many people are yelling
about me tickets for my Chicago shows
went on sale there are three shows
Friday Saturday Sunday no sorry Thursday
Friday Saturday and Thursday Friday sold
out and like literally everyone's
yelling at me like there's still the
Saturday show relax there's plenty of
tickets if you want to go please get
Saturday tickets and I will look into
movie doing some more shows like people
yelling at me like I'm sorry I'm sorry
anyway it's just thing I was reading
some of the comments remember like when
we used to get our hair and makeup done
for the show and like we looked so crazy
sometimes we look terrible I look at
some episodes in the eyebrows that they
put on me like were horrendous so yeah
the only now we're easy breezy
I never did my makeup with there I just
did my hair well you just got a part in
some hairspray yeah I could do that for
you here no I do that my own now yeah I
got a comb combs are everything you
don't have a comb with a rat tail you're
not living the rat tail is what's key
but also the comb Park is like you tell
your part and then you close you down
and by the and then you just like took
ten years on new life had I know not in
high school like I would have probably
been like the most popular prom queen
yeah if they had that you would have
been um do you know what kind of rat
tail do you have I have the longest no
like what color is the tail Lac I have a
blonde honeycomb Amazon sells a rat tail
that's unbelievable I bought it it's
literally like a needle it's like silver
and pointy no and it's so precise Wow
I highly suggest it I stole it from
Olivia sometimes I just use the end of
like my highlighter brush if I'm like
yeah exactly
okay you ready for the past five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast no just I would like to show
that's what my rumor about the tick is
because everyone's yelling you know
everyone's saying okay so if you're a
patreon member you get access to like if
we when we do merch they'll get early
access if we do chose do you get early
access to tickets so I gave the patreon
people early access to tickets but only
set aside a certain amount for them like
so I wouldn't be fair if like they all
sold out during presale but so now
everyone's yelling at me saying that I
sold out the ticket whatever you know I
don't talk about this since when is
selling out a problem since people like
a ligament and you have one show that
has tickets available thank you and it's
in the suburbs which like I feel like
it's gonna be lit mething like nothing
goes nothing like and if someone one of
you like lives in the suburbs mike wants
it to our house party grass oh my god
any suite would be there also I haven't
decided if I'm coming you know I've
never been to Chicago Chicago I feel
like I should go to Chicago they have
like this innovative road are you gonna
sing the Rascal Flatts concert oh I
think he might be and I don't know if I
can sacrifice Rascal Flatts
it's in New Jersey with dan + Shay in an
outdoor venue that's like made for
country music's our soap so and we've
been like planning this for so long
the new boat take it to it like we're
getting them for free for free maybe oh
just I'm
you are [ __ ] are you sure it's the 28th
it totally is it's the 27th if it's the
27th I will die but it's the 28th like
there's no doubt in my mind so I don't
know Chicago Rascal Flatts but like you
know if it's not a group saying like
it's not we were gonna get a pickup
truck and tailgate you know I mean
Chicago's not a group thing it's just
bad I meant if the concert understand
Olivia and tak yes pyro oh my god that
is so upsetting yeah I sorry I didn't
okay I'm sorry to break the news um what
we're housekeeping today's Wednesday me
usually due to your toasters but because
we have Ryan Serhant we'll be doing to
your toasters tomorrow so if you have
advice that you need advised on email to
your toasters at gmail.com Jackie give
us the first story okay this first story
is strange our Nick Jonas and periagua
Chopra dating all the convincing
evidence from enews okay it's like
literally this news came out liber8 all
at once yesterday like it's like someone
decided we could talk about it and then
everyone rub it up okay here's the quote
convincing evidence but one of us is not
convinced no Jonas and Priyanka Chopra
have officially sparked romance rumors
with not one but three consecutive
get-togethers the pop singer and
Quantico actress former are finding
quite a bit of time together hope
hopping from the Hollywood Bowl to
Dodger Stadium and then the Pacific
Ocean island when weekend bother sounds
like a fun weekend Hollywood Bowl had
Beauty in the B side I saw which is my
dream and I saw Holly and I saw an
Instagram story at the Hollywood Bowl
and like I was about to say the
Hollywood read the Hollywood Bowl and
it's like not it's like you get a table
like I had a restaurant shut up yeah
it's not like seats I think that's so
interesting cuz the only experience I
have what the Hollywood boughs when they
went there for a date on The Bachelor
know though and then in my head there
was no one there anyway when Nora Jones
performed
oh my god that's how I know it that's
crazy okay it all started Friday with
multiple outlets reporting that Nick and
Priyanka watch Beauty and the Beast live
in concert in Los Angeles despite
showing quote no obvious PDA during the
show as weekly reports the pair is in
fact dating and both interested in each
other their Memorial Day weekend
adventures continued into Saturday when
the rumored coupled cheered on the City
of Angels home team as they face the San
Diego Padres
an onlooker tells a news of Nick and
Priyanka is dynamic they were both very
happy and smiley and seem to be really
enjoying each other's company they
didn't show any PDA just talking and
laughing a lot the cherry on top of the
duo's Shirley unforgettable
Dave ooh a cozy boat ride with pals
Priyanka clad in the yellow sweatshirt
snuggle next to the jealous singer for a
photo op alongside Glen Powell Wilmer
Valderrama and Chord Overstreet okay I
just wanna take a moment to say I'm in
love with Glen Powell I met him
really yeah oh and I have so much to
tell you who is he worthy of being in
love with um yeah he's hot as hell he
was on that trip to Mexico that I meant
to he said you guys from two of my
favorite TV's and movies TV shows
screams scream queens and hidden figures
oh I don't know who hidden because is
one of my favorite movies and spoons is
my favorite show wait you want to you
want to be really insane the astronaut
he does was so nice I didn't I didn't
know who he was when I met him but
they're like it's Glenn I was like okay
so nice Wow okay so I got invited on a
trip like this past weekend but we were
in the Hamptons and like I don't really
want to go all the way to Mexico guess
was there okay like you're gonna die Lea
Michele wait first two letters are
correct but it's a boy Liam Hemsworth
Barry I'll give you clue Leonardo
DiCaprio yes I could have been in Mexico
with Lea another to get really honest
that doesn't do it for me like it's he I
just feel like I wasn't like I'm just
like a few years younger than the girls
were I'm not even obsessed with him like
physically attracted wise but like I
could have been on trip with me we just
like one like watch him like you know
Steve Irwin watching and yeah I'm the
jungle like watching him party and like
pick up chicks whatever look what I
found that out I have like a lot of foam
up from the trip
oh and that wouldn't give me like
honestly Lea Michele should have been
like oh my god but she wasn't there
right because that sounds like you and
Leo have no business being free no I
would have to sing down in my parade I
think in with Lea Michele you have
nothing that's not true
we both care about the environment and
you both like like models I do
wait okay okay so they want us to think
that they're dating which makes me think
that they're not dating as a couple they
make absolutely no sense
right so here's the thing Priyanka is in
my opinion so much more elevated like
celebrity wise count like she's just so
far beyond Nick Jonas he's like a boy
and he's four feet tall and like I don't
get why older women love Nick Jonas
enough for her no not at all or a
prestigious enough I just I don't think
it's happening
she's a goddamn royal wedding like we
went to the Radio Disney musical total
or GMA's they're not date some could
argue though that the are GMA's are more
prestigious no even I will make that
argument the Royal Wedding is as we eat
it a whole episode a whole episode to
the RDMA no no it makes no sense it's
definitely not true she could do so much
better and if it is true I will be
wildly disappointed in her I just I know
that it's sensual but I feel like she is
agreeing to this for the press this PR I
mean it's not a bad look for her Nick
Jonas like is a cool dude
he's like one of my celebrity crushes so
I don't know why I keep putting him down
maybe I'm just jealous probably speaking
of I have a new celebrity crush a boy or
a girl a boy who's it you're gonna be
shocked do charades something yes okay
um there's it's a couple different
facets a week but the podcast listeners
can't hear straight okay no flowers okay
Rose rose his name is rose uh no hmm how
am I gonna do this it's in a movie about
a rose beauty of the beast well you're
not gonna get it because you didn't
watch The Bachelor
oh but Colton Underwood is a contestant
on The Bachelor grace means XY no
usually he's not gonna he's not gonna
and I have the biggest Carson I know
he's hot as hell he's hot as hell he's
so cute
every time he's in the background of a
scene he's just being like cute and like
smiley but here I have questions because
I'm confused
is it Ali Raisman like 15 that's okay so
that's what I was saying YouTube no
she's like 23 I think what and so he's
definitely young I forgot how old he is
but that he's not gonna win I don't
think but he needs to be our bachelor
like a successful bachelor who like is a
little bit famous to begin with so we
not like just a thirsty Rando and he hid
now his full-time job because he's not
in the NFL anymore he runs a charity
organization and he is just so handsome
and he's a virgin so like he just has
like he'll appeal to so many different
people okay and he's appealing to me no
I don't want to become like rude or
anything about birds let me first of all
let me find out how old he is before
you've started calling him a 40 year old
virgin oh I'm not gonna say that I would
say
he is okay I'm just getting his numbers
for the team Justin I tell you oh he's
my age 24
so he's 26 he just turned 26 twists six
well I'm turning 26 November okay I
think being a virgin is beautiful like
waiting I really do like I've only had
sex with Ben I think it's lovely but
like at what point is does it become
weird look at what age what he says to
Becca in the previews for the rest of
the season it may be like the editors
misconstrued his words is that he's
still a virgin and it's not that he's
waiting till marriage he's just waiting
for the right woman so he didn't have
sex with Aly Raisman and no that's she
wasn't the right woman but then when I
heard that I'm like oh but makes sense
because she's 15 but she's not you're
telling me I'll tell you how old she is
this whole thing I don't know is
honestly if it wasn't for Colton I would
not continue watching the season of The
Bachelor how old is she has a couple of
really cute guys 1994 she's two years
younger than him so she's like 23 24
what do you think she's a virgin I
haven't thought it was so little but
she's not she's like she's no I meant
like physically I don't know I don't
know I don't know enough about these
people and now I have to watch the whole
season in The Bachelor to find out you
know I'm gonna watch wonder if the name
Aly Raisman would be dropped but so
here's what's interesting about the
bachelor and we're not recapping because
you didn't really watch but there's two
former NFL players Colton and one
current NFL player who's like legit
anything at the time we for so many
teams well they film in the winter and
remember we went to the Super Bowl in
February
hmm then bachelor ended in March so it's
actually really good timing for NFL
players and it had me thinking like
there's this season a lot of the men
have real jobs like they're kind of
prestigious ish we use that term loosely
here and you know who started all of
this and I have to give credit where
credit is let me think it's a boy or
girl boy Jordan Rogers Jordan Rogers
yeah cuz when Jordan Rogers went on The
Bachelorette it was like why would Aaron
Rodgers brother go on this show right
he's like shaming his family like this
is so beneath him he was went to
Vanderbilt played almost in the NFL like
what is he doing on the show but then he
made a real career and then like now is
a broadcaster for the SEC or something
yeah and I feel like it's a sec is the
one where they come in
like when money Bernie Madoff a sports
entertainment network Sen no he's he's
the broadcaster for like ESPN College
SEC whatever I think there must be two
but he made it like cool to you know get
a real job from Bachelorette and so like
I feel like Holden under what it's like
I mean tell you Jesse Palmer really
started it but that was just way too
young oh yeah that was different
anyways I just I have a big question
close another one I think he's gonna be
the next Bachelor and if he is Smits has
to go on
totally second I'm I'm getting more
inspired to watch because I'm like just
watching a lot of like Becca and she's
not as terrible as I thought she's not
terrible
she they've given her an amazing
clothing orange um in the previews for
the rest of the season like every look
is on point which I really really
appreciate yeah they're their stylist
does wonders Carrie um and she seems
like a nice girl
and I really believe that she wants to
get married and semi tuned and that's
all I need Behrman in order to believe
this farce bare minimum okay so the
question is are Nick Jonas and Priyanka
Chopra dating I'm gonna say no I'm gonna
say now on this but II news in the Daily
Mail want you to believe they are makes
me wonder why they want me to believe
that they are right look what's what's
your goal here right you know waste my
time well you have time consider my time
wasted speaking of a story that's the
opposite of a waste of time Real
Housewives of Dallas is Brandi Redmond
adopts a baby boy after fertility
struggles okay so this was something
that we thought had a lot of speculation
because like there was like a new baby
on social media I'm like they never
really addressed it and I'm curious why
they waited so long probably something
with production but now they've
officially announced had a whole people
my photo shoot to people that they
adopted a redheaded boy so Brandi
Redmon's fertility struggles were well
documented on season two of The Real
Housewives of Dallas
but when season 3 premieres the summer
she and husband Brian ooh the summer
that's exciting she and husband Brian
will have a surprise for fans infant son
Bruin Charles whom the couple welcomed
through adoption this past winter quote
it's changed our lives forever brandy
tells people exclusively of their new
addition who joins daughters Brooklyn 9
and brinkley 6 quote we are obsessed
with him my whole family is we're just
so blessed the couple's son born
prematurely on December 31st weighing
four pounds five ounces and measuring 18
inches and adopted via a closed adoption
has been a quote perfect fit for the fan
Bruin even has strawberry blonde locks
which match the brood of Redman redheads
it's crazy brandy says he'll always look
like he came from me which he did he
came from my heart oh this is so sweet
I'm so happy for them and wait someone
put some relevant information in the
comments
you can't show and adopt a child on
social media until everything is final
which can sometimes take a couple months
so that might be why they never like
fully address the whole story that's so
interesting
wait I just think it's honestly like
hilarious that they got an adopted
redheaded like it's just I have to
wonder if they like sought that out
instead they gave up on like other like
a less deserving kids because they don't
have red hair but I don't think that's
sad because I think it would have been
sad if the whole family had red hair and
then yeah would have had Outkast and
FedEx out kft vibes
even though FedEx was a redhead right
girls might have the tables have turned
oh I'm really I'm really happy for them
they have such a sweet family totally
and I always say that like I really
appreciate when people with like big
platforms or with TV shows like talk
about their fertility struggles because
I think it's like a really great thing
to do and I just something we have a
happy ending like with Giuliana Rancic
like we went through so much with a
number when she the show like we follow
along and then she finally got Duke like
I just love when there's a happy ending
and now what's the DC Bruins
so Brinkley Brooklyn Brinkley and Bruin
the sons of brandy and Brian there's a
non mother not only do they do all be
names they did be on yeah
brandy Brian brew in Brooklyn the [ __ ]
name is in Redmond and their family
redneck
it's so on brand they deserve their own
reality show just for that like the
Kardashians weekís yeah no they all
right control they have a nice family
brand that's around the room Brad are
you gonna like browse your family
no you're not gonna make your kids like
names like work within each other
well I'm thinking actually like since I
want five kids and maybe doing it
alphabetically
no I'm kidding I know that's your thing
that is my thing but I don't know let me
see beckon remember no no Shayla
situation totally you can't say your
baby's name you can't say your baby
seems one cuz it's a bad luck and two
like you [ __ ] ain't seen my baby's
names and also my movie names are like a
little weird so I have to wait to
showcase em until I have the baby and no
one's gonna be like that's weird be the
one that starts with an
is weird as hell I don't oh no it's not
it is no it's not it's so cute and
here's the thing I have a couple of baby
names that I'd like for a really long
time almost like five 10 years now and
my thinking is if I still like them by
the time I have babies then like I will
like them forever no but this is the
problem it's like forever I had a name
and then I met someone with that name
that I literally despise and now I can't
have the name so what are you gonna tell
us the name he'll know I think it'll be
so obvious actually no I think it was
one of my name's that I'm thinking of
the person no no if I say the name it'll
be so obvious because there's literally
like one person with the name okay so am
i sorry yet I'm not gonna make you do
that
but like name James that's a nice name I
feel like boy names are way easier oh my
god totally yeah because yeah boys names
aren't as trendy like it's so crazy to
think about how like the trends of names
like like the name like Debra you know
or like it's just Oh for older people
and they feel like that like it wasn't
an old people name 50 years a tiny name
so I feel like the name like Chloe or
something now is gonna like age totally
look Susan Carol yeah I understand yeah
like don't yes yeah I don't like the
names that like what's the word that
like are like they could go either way
like Alex Sam Dillon I actually do like
names I could go either right mostly
because one time this is a weird
childhood memory one time when we were
at day camp there was like a one of
those days where it's like a kind of
like a color war day and they main
announcement over speaker like you can
come come up and like get your prize if
your name can also be a poisoning what
you just made that up that is not true
not true
well I'm sorry it was if your last name
could also be a name for a seal st yeah
no idea
my name is like Taylor but like ashtray
is no you know it's called the first tee
last day if your name is like Corey
David which is a boy we went to high
school with and he's always my example
lassie if you're just a person who's at
first yes I'm Margot Lewin is a person
gossipy no yeah first feed laugh T is
when your last name could be a first
name - thirsty lassie is someone who
just referred to as therefore
in there last thing for no apparent
reason maybe that's true we have to ask
massive Locke the originator from first
class if you don't know the Massey
Bacchus you guys I can't [ __ ] yeah scram
when I do this like you ever school you
can let your finger wobble on its own
its I don't think I have that ability
scrap um okay have we only been through
one story we've been through to Priyanka
oh I was gonna say we could take our
sweet time but be kind me a brandy and
like I really want to dive deep third
story Kesha's latest attempts to
terminate contracts with doctor oh my
god rejected I know and again it gets
worse this infuriates me okay here's the
story while as dr. Luke defamation
lawsuit against former protege Kesha is
still pending her attempts to extradite
herself from contracts she signed with
him and his Kemosabe label have been
halted again on Tuesday a New York
appeals court affirmed a judge's
decision to reject Kesha's counterclaims
the latest in several attempts by her to
have her agreements with gottwald
terminated it Gottwald is dr. Luke the
news was first reported by The Hollywood
Reporter the countersuit was first
stymied in March of last year when New
York Supreme Court Justice Shirley corn
rice supported dr. Luke's attorneys
argument that the singer should have
provided notice of alleged contract
breaches and that her allegation of the
impossibility of her performing under
the deals which he claimed due to her
troubled relationship with the producer
was based on speculation that decision
was arguably supported by the fact that
Kesha released an album rainbow has
performed frequently and is setting out
on tour with Macklemore this summer what
Kesha's proposed amendments are palpably
insufficient and devoid of merit the
decision reads her counterclaim seeking
declaratory relief terminating the
agreements on the ground of
impossibility and impact ability of
performance was speculative contradicted
by her own allegation situation were
forming under the agreements and as to
at least one of the agreements the
impossibility was not produced by an
unabated invent that could have been
foreseen or guarded against why now why
this sperm mean either basically she
dropped she appealed again to get out of
her contract they said no and now dr.
Luke is counter suing her for 50 million
dollars but it's like not cool bro no
you don't get to assault someone and
then sue them for 50 million dollars
Kesha go free Kesha like we're in such a
time where it's like how is this
happening
also like no offense to Kesha I don't
think she's like that much of a
moneymaker that like dr. Lewton needs
her to survive like she's just getting
by with her one good song no I feel like
she does well enough for her but yeah
she's not not just a state a whole label
I just did dr. Lucas just being like a
power-hungry
[ __ ] that's why I was helping
her like hella script is helping her
yeah but like Taylor Swift alone like
who will own dr. gloops labels it's
still Sony I have no idea but like know
why all those [ __ ] on stage didn't
train with her that's literally was
about to say we're in the Grammys like
licking cashes eating moon and then
where are you today Grammys but Taylor
Swift is the only one who helps she be
at all she 250 Grammys could put
pressure on dr. Luke to let her go like
someone could yeah everyone could and
it's just I don't understand how this is
happening in 2018 I don't have a message
for you hi I have a message dr. Luke I
know do you want I seriously I hope you
find your piece fallen on your knees I
thought you were gonna know my ass is
too good for dr. Luke he's an assaulter
and he would probably try to eat it
without permission cuz he's in a Saltire
and you know that's not cool very fair
anyways justice for Kesha for [ __ ]
real like literal justice I'm here
justice consider it served no it's not
served consider it needing to be served
serve it someone me or them we're
powerless order like someone who's
watching has power
please help Kesha stained or money
overruled I done do you know any no I
don't know any other jargon bailiff
bring in the dancing lobsters I will
hold you in contempt of court that's a
good one okay this next story is a
little strange and gives me like
Priyanka Chopra and Nick Jonas sides oh
yeah that kendall Jenner is dating NBA
star Ben Simmons like when did she break
up with all the other boyfriend she all
the other NBA stars I thought she was
with that Blake Griffith yeah and then
someone else
I don't know kendall Jenner is 18
Philadelphia 70
sixer Ben Simmons multiple sources tell
page six exclusively or the 76ers in the
play in the championships
I think they works I went to a Philly
bar with Rebecca to watch a game so how
long ago um it was allergy season I
think it was two weeks ago they were in
the playoffs I don't know if they
they're not in anymore
how do you know whose fame the
championship okay I could tell you I
don't trust in Thompson's the Tristan
Thompson's the Cleveland Cavaliers verse
it was the Rockets OH
James Harden I don't know nope
yeah the Cavaliers are playing with
Celtics and their rockets for playing
the Phillies Phillies how to team that's
baseball anyone who's in the Jimmy
gentleman ghost offensive on Devon and I
they've been in the championships
together for the past three years which
like someone ain't working you guys I
have something controversial we need to
do a credible division of assets totally
I think what assets are not great I just
want to say something about basketball
I'm not about that swell about the
Golden State Warriors and why they don't
have my support
two words I you sugary and I know it's
really mean but her show and Food
Network is so [ __ ] horrible and like
I just hate when people get stuff
because of like people they're married
or related you like so you don't just
get a Food Network show because your
husband's really good at basketball like
and the show is so stupid and like it's
like they pay Stephan to come into every
episode like once like hey baby what are
you cooking you know like it's so
annoying and she like makes a worse [ __ ]
and it's so obvious that like they have
to film the show twice like one with her
talking and one with her cooking and
then like film the hands separately
because like she's not good at the
multitasking it's just such a bad show
like it pisses me off and they always
just like coming back from playing
basketball you know it's like please
stiff I'm like I know you're doing other
things it's just well I'm personally
great sorry I'm rooting for the
Cavaliers I'm rooting for this to fons
because I read a crazy plan about
Stephane oh I got it too and now he was
he in a good way that's extorted like
basically this is why blinds are so
crazy
it was very vague and it said that
basically someone tried to blackmail
Stephan curry for something he did not
do and he like he like almost like had
to pay like millions of dollars to get
this story that wasn't even true to get
it canned
but then like some there was some weird
turnover that's whatever basically the
blind was like not he said they said
it's tough on curry don't be surprised
if in the next few months you see there
owns a major media company or looks like
a multi-million dollar something and
literally like a month ago it was
announced that Steph Curry has like a
huge deal with the Sony like it's just
so crazy the blinds predict the future
yeah um but I'm rooting for the
Cavaliers because the Theo's so now I'm
truly always a cavalier
oh that's true I realize that okay let's
do frozen Khan's Khan Pro of the
Cavaliers is CEO he's a Cavalier yeah
Hanukkah Cavalier is the Tristan
Thompson's right but probe the Cavaliers
LeBron James train wreck that's good -
yeah konna the Cavaliers
it's a Cleveland like and just like
Kannan the Cavaliers is like they always
wait but you could also say that about
the other game so now golden oh so pro
of the Cavaliers is Chloe and she needs
like a little prestige like no I
disagree Khan Aisha and the Cleveland
people are always like shaming her like
she made Tristan mad at basketball and
they're yelling at her in the streets
and like now they'll be praising her
Kobe doesn't walk in the street you
never tell that episode of Kardashians
where they're like [ __ ] the Kardashians
said okay fine
Khan of the stefan's is the iishe of a
tall pro of the stephane is the
multi-million dollar show detail of it
all so I don't know last place her
Golden State David Lee I don't know oh
and he's hot and you know who he's
engaged to David Lee okay David Lee like
us-- playing the Knicks and he was like
the belle of the ball of New York okay
at the ball lol and then he moved to
Golden State he was like really good
there too I think he might be retired
but he's engaged to Caroline Wozniacki
and they're so cute that's cute and she
is the biggest ring like of all time
oh good I'm happy for them I don't know
them that I'm happy yeah no they look
alike which is weird but it's good
they're like a look-alike and that's our
Sports report I'm going Cavaliers I'm
gonna go Golden State okay that'll be
good for the show shoot bet okay
and whoever wins okay let's split money
though because I want to win money
okay hundred dollars well what's the
spread no just like that they'll take it
all okay but see that's like it's
supposed to be like get your odds know
there are odds
I know overall who wins the whole thing
and we'll bet $100 whoever wins gets 100
ollars so 50/50 each cuz then actually
got $100 or 100 100 if you'ii both put
in 50 then the winner here has to give
the winner $100 what are you talking
about okay put in $50 look into what
it's a poker yes I'm the table then we
would get a fundraiser who's the winner
$100 the loser gives the winner Hydra
dollars okay [ __ ] Tristan if you let
me down I will come too I was better
than $50 i $100 from you
what's the champ for Golden State we
should do a whole bet like I don't know
if this is illegal but like in the
toaster screw it's 100% illegal stop
talking sorry okay let's move on it's
our final story well I wanted I just
give you the details about Kendall
Jenner's new fake Oh an insider familiar
with the duo said the bromance has been
going on for a few weeks while page six
was also reporting that she was
romancing break livin like Griffin Blake
Griffin another source notice the pair
was spotted this week on a lunch date at
the Beverly Hills Hotel and a third
source says that Jenner and Simmons were
seen last week in Manhattan with a group
of friends at the club e berry
restaurant vandal okay band Ellie's harp
okay no that's all you know that story's
false because nobody cool goes to vandal
anymore oh my god vandal was the biggest
disappointment oh my god literally he
was like the one cool restaurant and we
tried so hard and we got there we got a
reservation and we were with the people
I went like three times in one month I
was like every time the food it was so
bad there their idea was like a little
bit of the best who's this global
cuisine so it's not like Italian it's
not French it's a cuisine of the world
please please just so like he thought no
it's a good idea like you would have
pizza from Italy Russia right but they
chose like the worst menu items from
every country yeah it's like here's the
worst food in the world and there was
there it was inedible yeah so don't go
there if you're coming to New York
security measures seem to have been
taken to ensure Kendall and Ben enjoyed
their night inside hassle-free oh that's
just a convenient for like we didn't
actually see them take a break okay this
is a big story
I'm calling fake news so who's Ben
Simmons and literally not only does it
make no sense for Kendall today than NBA
player because they're never home his
home is in Philly so like he's really
never away and it's not like he plays
for the Knicks like she goes to New York
I doubt Kendall
spends more than six hours a year in
Philly I doubt caramel gender has ever
even been to Philly no she totally has
yeah I'm like a seventh grade class trip
to see the Liberty Bell yeah I mean I
did see I saw national treasure such
history okay last story I like love mal
Clooney is helping Meghan Markel settle
into London life they have a court
natural friendship okay this is
something that makes sense to me yeah
these who were born to be friends Amal
Clooney is more than just a wedding
against guests to Prince Harry and
Meghan Markel she's the new Royals
confidant okay I don't know about
courtship Megan and Amol have known each
other for a while and share many
interests
the two were introduced by a mutual
friend and got closer after the suit
star moved to the UK we're doing a mall
in Georgia Liam I feel like there were
just citizens and citizens of the world
yeah I guess there's a POTUS is the moon
yeah like this is the thing I like love
hate them all like I'm a jealous of her
do you know what I mean like I don't
hate her for any particular reason other
than the fact that I'm incredibly
jealous of her life her wardrobe her
husband and like her but her future
features her future okay and like she
has such big when they got married and
they went on that boat in Venice and
like she Wars that little floral dress
you know what I'm talking about that
moment like that is a moment that like
I'm jealous of no she was when I shoot
so many people that I'm putting in
Itasca dive like what does she worry
about yeah oh my god totally and when I
hear her name like I roll my eyes but
only because I'm incredibly jealous of
everything she has are you in child are
you jealous of Meghan but see like
Meghan okay to me they have similar
lives but Meghan's it's under so much
more scrutiny and like so much she
doesn't get as many of the perks as a
mother right like a mom can still party
and drink awesome ego so you know a man
can Megan go to the Met Gala
no definitely not but if willing Kate
I've never been to the Met Gala I know
they should be another house said so
like I don't know I'm just like they
should do a royal theme for them and
let's don't mistake my my detest of Amal
Clooney for anything other than just
pure and utter jealousy okay thank you
for being so loyal to Megan mark
obviously for admitting that um like my
jealousy for Amal Clooney like it's
actually just a love for her you know
I'm not that I agree with
you're Megan jealousy like lookin people
were like you're so mean talking about
Megan on her wedding day like you're
obviously just jealous like yeah no [ __ ]
like she's a princess like look at us
we're in a sari people I didn't even
brush my hair this morning okay and
Megan marker like had someone brush your
hair for her twice already
okay yes you uncovered a secret I'm
jealous
please [ __ ] you anyways I'm so here for
the friendship of these two and I just
feel like together they're just gonna do
like so much humanitarian no it's so
gonna save the world
they are wonder women it's the perfect
friendship and I'm just looking forward
to all the good they're gonna do
together right for women for everything
for everything also Megan and Harry are
on their honeymoon in Alberta to New
York Times said is the most boring place
on earth knows a New York Post New York
Times is another funny right I was gonna
like when I heard the near ten today I
was like wow no it was a near post and
for some reason when I think of Alberta
Canada I just think of Kaitlyn Bristowe
scene what is Alberta
it's a province oh what a province like
a state sort of it's I don't I don't
understand how it works eh I'm not gonna
pretend to yeah I mean either except
honestly canvas live but they're going
to the same place that Queen Elizabeth
on her honeymoon and Queen Elizabeth
well that's prestigious I guess I wonder
what they're gonna do I don't know just
like if you have all the money in the
world all the connections in the world
we're kinda jet
you're gonna Canada I would go to like
the French Polynesian islands south of
France something yeah a boat but maybe
it's like you could go anywhere and it's
like then it's just you know what we'll
go to Canada no I mean I guess if you've
been a royal for your whole life like
Megan's one year and she doesn't wanna
use any of the perks yeah private jet
you have to worry about anything
speaking of perks you finally watch
dynasty yeah oh my god I find I finished
Shaughnessy on Sunday and I just have to
say it's the best show of all time we
need to make it Riverdale 2.00 dare I
say it was better than Riverdale thank
you sister
because you want to know what CW is a
really good job of doing of making like
set designs like Riverdale has like this
aesthetic that's so unique to Riverdale
it's like gloomy and it's new you it's
like suburban like it's perfect dynasty
like the glamour was just like so there
the clothes
housed the jet the cars like it was just
dial AG the richness was so there that
even on a boring episode like with
[ __ ] Sami just parents like boring it
was just so beautiful to watch and it's
like there's so much it's crazy to think
about like the first drama that unfolded
like every episode really is jam-packed
and like even if you're not loving a
storyline like this too shall pass and I
know the last episode was so crazy the
last few episodes were so crazy and I'm
in love with his Liz Gillies she carried
the show for the first like five
episodes and I honestly like not to
sound like a lesbian or anything but
like her boobs like are amazing and I
couldn't stop thinking about like how
she has the perfect boobs and I think
that they're real
she has also like a perfect body yes she
she has it she has it going on I really
like crystals not as much as I love
Palin but you guys need to watch that we
can all talk about it in the ministers
and just get excited about season two
because there is a season two coming but
we need to like get those numbers up you
guys and no one can do it like the
toasters no nobody can we basically
invented Riverdale and let's amend the
show - no I'm serious yeah and kissing
booth I like I want to do a Twitter poll
member we did a poll of like how many
people we got to watch Riverdale like
the amount of people telling me that I
got them to watch kissing booth dislike
I need to know how many I would say like
roughly 5,000 like so many people how
many people do you think we got to watch
Riverdale about the same yeah mm-hmm
well let us know if you watch trying to
see so we can all go over it in the
meantime it is time for our esteemed
guests yes so as per usual we are gonna
take a brief 2 to 3 minute break get all
set up with Ryan Serhant and then we
will be back live so if you oh my god if
you have any questions for Ryan Serhant
about million-dollar Westing Celt like
Serhant about what it's like to be
married to a Greek goddess you let us
know you leave a comment on the Facebook
stream and we will get it to him so
we'll see you in a minute I'm actually
watching on YouTube so cool
you
yeah
we are back with the king of celli
if you want to learn to sell it like
Serhant stay tuned because Ryan Serhant
is here we're so excited that he's here
we got a ton of questions mostly about
your wife so I guess a lot about you
but you have your own show now and your
million-dollar listing like forever
since the beginning right how does it
compare like having the spotlight to
yourself as opposed to having to share
it with Fredrik and others the other guy
yeah it's better it's better but it's a
lot more pressure to write because I get
to a million dollar listing there's
three of us in the show is split up
evenly between the three and so I get to
kind of like weave in and out but sound
like Serhant is all me all the time yeah
so it took a longer time to film it yeah
but it's also like a passion project
like this you know it's it's helping
people that actually need help versus
just showing you know some
multi-millionaire right he doesn't like
a coffee table break and the feedback
has been looks just from what I've seen
is so positive because it's like a much
more emotional show yes and I wondered
like what was your involvement how did
it start like have you had this idea for
a while yeah so maybe NAR listing
started but we stick asset in 2010 like
a year after I got into the business and
then it came out in 2012 and once it
came out people email they write the DM
tweet etc saying like hey I watched last
night's episode and the way you
negotiated I did the same thing to a guy
today and I sold ten more tires right
love Bill from Iowa right and so I just
kind of kept saving all of that stuff
and seven years later it turned into a
separate show where I go into different
jobs every single episode kind of like
quantum leap a long time ago but there's
every episode is a different job and I
go in and help like a real profit right
yeah different business but these sales
people and not like the business as a
whole right and they're all like really
really really struggling and it was
really hard to do but it was incredibly
fulfilling ya know and like just
watching it it's like gives me like
tabatha takes over bad yeah but you're a
lot nicer you tell me the time is so
scary if she came on our show and you
just oh oh nice do I love
so I have a hard time being like really
mean to people who are truly trying
really hard and like need help I'm
really struggling like I'm passively
mean with like a twist of humor to it
right right like you got to be kind of
funny funny like yeah yeah exactly yeah
exactly um you've been a brothel
everyday now for seven years
um what would you say is your favorite
part about being a part of the Bravo
family cuz I know what my favorite part
would be but I'm just curious to hear
yours honestly is that it's it's such a
massive machine you know like that's not
a really sexy answer to that question
but it's it's like when you're on a
Bravo show like people will watch the
shows who don't have any interest in
what you're doing but they are Bravo
fans right like you do not real estate
bad right exactly and so like people
from all over the world watch it and for
me as a salesperson the more people who
know what I'm selling the better yeah so
people who don't even know what we do
will watch it in like South Korea
because they really like southern charm
right or below Jack med and they'll see
it and then they'll email and say hey I
saw your you're some dude from New York
anyway my sister needs a place in near
Central Park and that's it's a huge flow
of business for us Wow
so do you get a lot of business request
via DM I mean when million dollar
listing started I was doing
predominantly rentals in Koreatown and
now things are different
right yes how did you get what was the
casting process like for the million
dollar listing I went to an open casting
call at the Hudson Hotel in Times Square
with 3,000 real estate agents from March
of 2010 I can imagine it was like the
douchiest guys like honestly I don't
remember I just remember it being like a
line out the door and it took forever
and then they cast it like they just
kept cutting it down and cutting it down
cutting it down until December of 2010
and then I got a call that they were
casting four of us well and the one
person who wasn't gonna make it would be
cut after the whole filming season so
that's why the first season like I go
really hard and a little crazy yeah yeah
well you have this like funny
relationship with Frederick and
Frederick now also has a second show
Frederick and Bethany yes like where you
feeling left out when they we're doing
the show or would you much prefer to be
doing so like survive I suppose like
another real estate show
yeah they well the show's got picked up
at the same time so like I didn't know
that he was doing a separate one he
didn't know I was doing separate one we
were actually both in Paris last year
for his 40th birthday party filming when
the news hit and we both looked at each
other we're like great that's great
yeah ideal yeah exactly you had to do a
show with another Bravo Liberty or a
real housewife who would you want to do
one with who would I want to do one with
honestly I would probably do like a
below deck because I love boats and I
love like the Mediterranean I would be
on that but I would be on it as like the
captain of course would be awesome yeah
not for everyone else mostly for me and
then you'd see my mean side because that
would be a show or I'm allowed to be me
[Laughter]
shows are great and they're sick they're
a great network and they're really
really supportive so it's been it's been
really really awesome and you have to
get married on today yes and I always
I'm so curious about the logistics
behind that like did Bravo they didn't
pay for the wedding obviously but did
you were able to like it get some free
stuff because your wedding was on nope
no nothing I got married in Greece oh
yeah drama doesn't air in Greece okay no
II actually was the exact opposite
because she's great she's from Athens
her whole family's there and so we
wanted to get married there like we had
to be really careful about what we told
people because I could go to a foreign
country saying hey we're from New York
we want to come other films he would do
it they're like oh the price is now this
much I'm sure this would be great like
they don't the whole world vacations in
Greece yeah like our wedding was big and
expensive but was probably the smallest
wedding that that island had seen in
like years like there's a Lebanese
wedding that it happens just before us
where the family spent five million
dollars Wow so we came in with like our
like 300 people and some cameras and
they're like okay you guys go yeah
one of the questions we got for you is
like would you say on a scale from one
to ten how true is the movie My Big Fat
Greek Wedding because you now live it I
sort of lived through it but not because
Amelia's Greek Greek and so there's
Greek Greek and then there's an American
Greek so American Greek it's incredibly
true yeah so she has family members that
are here that are like Greek American
and
it's it's like a historical documentary
no movie but then in Greece Greece it's
very different like it is hardcore Greek
hardcore yeah
like I'm gonna name my kids oooh stuff
are you oh that's nothing to me what is
your what is your track for kids do you
want like a million kids we're working
on it it's um a million kids I think
would be aggressive yeah I think we want
like the minimum of three but everyone
says have one first see if you survive
yeah yeah we both say we want like ten
and then we're gonna have one I'll be
like you know okay we got a lot of
viewer questions for you so we're just
gonna rapid fire sure how difficult was
it to shut down Times Square for your
proposal incredibly difficult took six
months and an insane amount of money and
who did you talk to the mayor's office
the NYPD the FDNY who was the mayor the
Times Square Alliance when I yeah I
think was at the time good question yeah
he's been there for a while what do you
think de Blasio does to the market like
like it's even effect on the market yeah
of course he does
he scares people when he told you taxes
right oh yeah okay a lot of taxes
already but more than anything I mean
the big difference I think as you see in
New York if you just drive around New
York is dirtier and there are yeah just
more crime and foreigners is my traffic
they take notice that like if you go to
vote if you go to Paris like if you go
to other European cities like they are
[ __ ] yes span and York can be a little
bit I mean not really at the end of the
day New York is is one of a kind and
everyone in the world wants to be here
yes what's the most expensive apartment
you've ever sold ever ever yeah man I
mean we sell out entire building so it's
kind of a different game that way yeah
but recently the most expensive last
month we did something on Park Avenue
for 36 I mean we did something Elizabeth
4:30 yesterday we sold something for
13.7 on Worcester what is the most
expensive area in the city most
expensive area in the city I mean is
that 5th Avenue corridor but at the end
of the day probably Soho we're late now
I don't want to live we know we're not
to go yeah what do you thinks the best
bang for your buck in the city
Greenpoint
no sorry in the city oh well I include
Brooklyn in Manhattan the best bang for
your buck is the Far East Side that's so
York at first because now you have the
second have any subway so there's good
deals up there yeah probably the best
bang for the buck by far and it's still
like nice yes exactly
look Louis said I'm sure like it's like
a little dirty it's good you still get a
good bang for your buck but you live in
dirt all right yeah it's still clean out
and address me know recited each village
is expensive now it is yeah I can't it
is expensive what do you think about
Steve gold and would you ever invite him
to be a part of your team you have to
watch this season to find out that's a
unique question because his brokerage
that he was with just grew from gray and
so now he's at a new brokerage but Steve
gold is great you know I've known him
for a long long time so he was one of
the people that we kind of when we knew
Lewis was leaving you know the crew kind
of came to us and said hey who do you
think would be good to put up and put up
a couple names and his was one of them
and it's worked out so far you're
friends with Louise yeah I mean a little
bit I don't know where he is and he was
like the whole world yeah it's crazy his
lifestyle he was hysterical yeah I don't
think he was right for the show but joy
watching him try good people love Louise
yeah that's for sure how do you get
started in real estate I was broke I
came to the city when I graduated
college to be an actor and that didn't
work out really really hard to make
money and then so I think my hand
modeled for a while that didn't work out
we got a close-up on these hands so yeah
I hand modeled I've really long fingers
and I don't have a whole lot of veins or
freckles so I would be like you know I
could fit my hands would look like
woman's hands or Matt's hands apparently
and so I would I would do I think so I
would hand model watches and Nespresso
capsules and AT&T phones
so can you juice and hand my only frost
like say you were modeling this watch
say it would just clear be like this
tell us this watch like that a little
bit yeah right and then espresso
capsules you'd have to go like this I
don't know if you could see if you have
to go like this and then you'd have to
like bend the metatarsal in the ring
finger and so then at the shoots they
would have like hand masseuses that
would come over right there like mr.
head yeah it would be really really hard
that's fine yeah and so then I went
broke
and that was the summer of 2008 and a
friend said listen don't be a waiter
don't be a bartender just get your real
estate license it's a couple hundred
bucks right departments where you live
which was Koreatown at the time and pay
your rent and go from there and that's
what I did and my first day was the day
Lehman Brothers filed for bankruptcy oh
yeah
well see now I have a question for you
so you started million dollar listing
soon after you became a real estate
agent yeah and now you've been working
real estate for almost ten years ten
years do you think you would be at the
level you're at now if it weren't for
the show no do you think you'd be close
I don't know actually
because the show really is it's a it's a
public shame shotgun yes like at the
beginning right the phone didn't start
ringing off the hook yeah at all like it
was only on honestly until like season
five when people would feel comfortable
reaching out but how many people do you
see on TV where you pick up the phone
you're like hey call Kendall no no you
don't do that exactly so people kind of
see it as television and it's off limits
so for those first couple years it was
really really hard but I used the show
as a way for me to just work harder and
make more phone calls and send more
emails hustle harder because I was like
I'm gonna be on a reality TV show to the
whole world selling real estate
if I fail on TV the whole world will
know that I can't bail I mean so
probably another very popular question
we got for you is like the logistics of
the show like what percentage of it
would you say is real script
honestly we it takes us nine months to
make it because it's I think it's like
too real I wish if like my life would be
so much easier if it was like three
months and we kind of knew exactly what
we were doing yeah but it's not like
they follow deals as they happen as they
go on they follow
yeah these like a ten million dollar
apartment doesn't sell in a day
I know it's New York so they fill them
the open houses so it's more you know I
think maybe the reason people feel that
way that things are like put together
maybe is because it all gets edited so
it's nine months of footage yeah there's
a lot of stuff that gets film showings
open houses conversations that at the
end of the day can't make it into 45
minutes so it gets cut well what's the
biggest challenge of now like writing a
very like big business and also having a
show is there a downside to it it's
finding the synergy
between like that work-life balance and
trying to stay as like compassionate for
work as I do at home
yeah and doing so like Serhant - I mean
that show took a significant amount of
time to do and it's much more I think
emotional yeah yeah and writing a book
like I wrote a book that comes out in
September like all that stuff together
it said so it likes their head calm it
called cell likes our hands it is so
what is it like to work with people on
Salt Lake Sirhan who are you know on the
verge of losing a lot hard like really
I'm not used to it I wasn't used to it
at all I mean the people I deal with all
day long are incredibly emotional but
they're emotional because they're not
getting 11 million they're only getting
ten point two right you know rich people
problems right exactly so it's like
that's those are the problems that I
deal with on a day in day out basis or
we're dealing with the developer who's
pissed off that one unit isn't selling
for the price he wanted but the whole
sale has a billion dollars right this
was people who like every episode
someone had just died or they were in
foreclosure or they were losing family
members like they had real issues that a
lot of people can relate to so it was it
was me dealing with helping them sell
and helping them become a better
salesperson but also 5050 helping them
become like a better person right that's
why the show turned out a lot more
emotional than I ever yes and are you
still in contact with any of the people
from certain episodes yeah all of them
oh that's great yeah yeah I check up on
them I'm like listen I'm like that scene
in Fight Club where I get their drivers
license and I'm like I will find you if
you're not on your path to being the
best salesperson ever in a year I will
know we do good yeah everyone needs a
teacher like that yeah we need to be
better salespeople yes I'm gonna show
okay it's premium content only okay
we are fun-loving gals young pop culture
yep what you did we could be doing
better doing better
mm-hmm um I don't know I think you guys
are pretty awesome everyone I told that
I was coming to do this literally like
I've done interviews with lots of
different people I have lots of crazy
celebrity clients I said I was coming
here and everyone's like shut up shut I
can't like can I come can I come and I I
got actually liked a little freaked out
it's like no I don't like I don't want
to stare them I've never met them before
like calm down
so great well actually when you bartend
I'm watch what happens i oh the first
time i barter not much happens i'd you
and Carol were the guests oh really
here's here's your converse Oh awesome
it's nice to know you've changed your
look a little oh that's hilarious well
so the final episode felt like star
hanasanai on tuesday yeah this coming
Tuesday you moved from Wednesday's what
does that mean it means that I think
another show decided to premiere on
Wednesday so they just pushed to the
same time son on Tuesdays yeah there you
go and the million dollar listing New
York comes back on June 12th very
exciting very busy guy thank you for
making the time that you keep up with
Ryan on Instagram at Ryan Serhant right
yes and on Twitter yes and on Facebook
yes John snapchat no you shouldn't it's
good to know that you're in tune with
what's necessary thank you guys for
tuning in make sure you follow the
morning shows on Facebook Instagram
YouTube and in the podcast app that way
you get a notification of every time we
go live which is Monday through Friday
10:30 a.m. Eastern Time we're back
tomorrow without a guest but we do have
Deere toasters so make sure you email
dear toasters at gmail.com if you want
some ill-advised advice we'll see you
tomorrow bye